i'm so excited to be sharing the kitchen
with not
one but two of my favorite people first
she's my culinary partner in crime and
co-author of our upcoming cookbook
rebel homemaker it's chef polar valdez
and next she's the founder of win coffee
supply america's first specialty
vietnamese coffee importer
and roaster she is also an incredible
activist who uses her platform to fight
for social justice
and racial justice please welcome sarah
wynn
back to the show thank you for having me
we've done so much in fact
we were talking before the segment pilar
made sarah a special surprise
yes i uh brought some um chili crisp i
took her coffee
out for a run and made a little chili
crisp and i brought it for her today
it looks amazing i cannot wait to try it
and then sarah's mom was kind enough to
make us her famous pork
and we got to eat it for lunch so thank
you
oh my god i'm gonna be so happy well
it's really nice to just have a family
vibe here
and sarah may is asian american and
pacific islander heritage month
and nobody is better to speak to this
than you
why is this so important that we pay
homage to this this month
first of all thank you so much for
creating the space drew so for
us apam or asian american pacific
islander heritage month is so
important to us because there's this
collective effort to humanize the asian
american experience
and like and over at one coffee supply
we're doing that by
using our platform to share stories from
our communities
to provide education around asian
american history
and to amplify asian american activists
well
you do
and you've been a really important
teacher on our show
and all over our digital and social
media
so you're just changing the narrative um
around
vietnamese coffee which i have been
sipping on and
i've always loved it with food
so pilar and i were talking and we were
like what about working with sarah
on a coffee cooking segment yeah i feel
like it was right after you had been on
the show
and i was like let's do recipes with her
coffee so we've come up
with not one not two but three
recipes and using coffee
so the first way we use sarah's coffee
actually
is as a spice rub so this one
is a grilled skirt steak and it has a
chili and coffee rub so
in there we have finely ground coffee
and then
to that we're going to add some chili
flakes some
smoked paprika some ground cumin
and some brown sugar all right so you're
going to season that all over the steak
yeah add it in water pack it in pack it
in there
so that looks really great drew so what
you're going to do is pour some oil
into the hot pan just a little bit
that's great and we're going to sear off
the steaks oh my gosh
that cooks off and then we actually have
a little bit of a swap
out finished seared steak on the side
and i like to serve it with a fennel and
arugula salad
so shall we give it a go i'm so excited
to taste your beautiful
coffee oh my god that coffee smells
really nice it smells so good
wow oh my god
the spices in the coffee yeah that rub
is really really wonderful
no you're a genius all right shall we
next up
yep next up coffee roasted beets so we
have a little bit of coffee
we have fennel seeds cumin and so
all the spices are actually whole and
what i'm gonna do
is lay the beets in those coffee
and spices and then we're gonna cover it
with a little bit of water
and basically you're gonna wrap it with
foil and roast it
at a 375 degree oven for about 45
minutes
and with the magic of television oh and
i love this with a salted yogurt sauce
shall we wow
um i couldn't love this dish more
wow so our last recipe for the day
and we're using brewed coffee and it's
in
a chocolate pot or a pot the creme
basically so
i know i'm ready i'm ready to just like
dig in
so with um sarah has over there
with tara has over there some egg yolks
and we're gonna um there's some sugar in
there as well and we're gonna whisk in
actually some of the brewed coffee
okay the whole thing yeah yeah so she's
gonna whisk that and then
she's going to combine the egg mixture
with the chocolate mixture
the chocolate mixture in front of her is
just some warmed up heavy cream
and some chocolate that has been melted
and mixed through
and then sarah when that's combined
you're going to mix in
the softened butter the room temp butter
so you've got everything in the bowl and
you let that set for at least two hours
and we topped it with a little whipped
cream because why not are we
feeling it now yes absolutely burn up
[Music]
oh my god i'm dancing
you guys i think i just got weak in the
[Music]
knees
thank you so much sarah thank you pilar
for blessing us for these amazing
recipes
cheers cheers
[Applause]
win go to the cheers show.com for all
three of these extraordinary recipes
and be sure to check out win coffee
supplies so you can get your hands
on this delicious coffee
you